hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest cube
I'm gonna put a seek out for a five
minute game okay here we go we got a
twenty twenty two seventy player just
try out for and Sicilian defense I will
go with the most commonly played moved
Knight f3 I'm not sure if I really want
to go into the open Sicilian I think I
think we'll just go with Bishop b5 and
try for something a bit more simple just
to exchange light square Bishop s'
simple development rook e1 Knight c3 or
actually maybe I might try C 3 and d 4 C
3 and d 4 might be something I'm going
to look to actually I'm gonna reserve
that option for just a moment place the
rook on e 1 and then maybe go forward
with C 3 and d 4 not sure really what
yet what I want to do you probably see
g6 so if I do C 3 C 3 and d 4 I think is
is gonna be something that's pretty good
establish two pawns in the center and
they're gonna have to be challenged at
some point I believe so how would how
would black go ahead and strike at these
two pawns that I have in the center now
since since this capture was made
already on d4 my knight is going to find
it well to be on c3 and my bishop what
to do with him okay so this is a nice
setup I could push forward with d5 kick
this Knight around where would that
Knight go actually I think this night
might want to come make use of this c4
square so he is pushing d5 just chasing
the knight to ask where that it already
wants to go to d5 then I that I have
eventually have to tolerate a night
landing on c4 this is a sensitive point
in my position for sure so what to do
instead he 5 is another possibility or
maybe just get my Bishop out hmm
Bishop e3 d5
maybe h3 cubbyhole for my king and it
would allow my bishop to come to e3
without being harassed by the Knight g4
move let's see let's try I'm gonna try
h3 h3 just a flight square for my king
and then I anticipated playing Bishop to
e3 on my next turn but actually you know
what that could still run into trouble
with just this Knight a5 9 c4 my bishop
would then be hit so I'm really not sure
this is um this is a I don't know how to
really guard this c4 square what to do
about that I think just castle or Knight
a5 or d5 these are just a few of the
moves that I'm kind of trying to
anticipate black playing Castle d5
Knight a5 Castle seems like it's a move
that's gonna have to be played so why
not do that one right away I really
don't see maybe a hurry with this knight
8 a 5 c4 idea I don't think it move like
EE 5 would be a good choice I could then
just play d5 and then this Bishop starts
to look very ugly since there's a on on
this a 5 square we have a bunch of
spectators rolling in here and I don't
know if you could hear in the background
but there's a bunch of kids going crazy
outside my house hopefully this guy
hasn't locked off I don't know it seems
like he's spending quite a bit of time
although I've I spent quite some time as
well
okay so we're pretty much dead equal
with regard to time and I'm starting to
really hesitate a bit with this Bishop
e3 move because anticipating Knight a5
c4 so I think I'm gonna have a change of
plans so I'm gonna go with Bishop f4
instead cuz I really don't like that
idea of knight Knight a5 c4 and then my
bishop would be attacked so that's
that's that's my reason for now
complaining to f4
so h3 I mean it still has its purpose of
providing a flight square for my king
but with regard to preventing the knight
from coming to g4 to attack my bishop
that's kind of out the door so what
should black be doing this is something
I wouldn't have considered really rook
on rook on F to d8 I don't see this D
file really opening up
so this file is already open so this is
a one of those logical moves rook to c1
and I'm still liking this Knight a5 move
Knight a5 or even d4 not sure what else
are maybe actually e5 is a possibility
maybe actually now I have enough
coverage over this 'if I've move so it's
kind of tough for I think black to
really do something constructive I think
this is the only I guess small plan but
now that my knight on c3 is defended by
my rook if Knight a5 I could play b3 and
I'm covering my sensitive point c4 so
what does black really do you know this
is this is um I guess a classic instance
where two pawns in the center really
really show themselves well so how to
really react to this d5 move whenever
there's a big change in the pawn
structure you know we usually have big
decisions so I'm thinking initially just
push forward kick this Knight around and
then maybe even a six so I'm not going
to spend too much time on that okay so
here's the trade-off I could win upon
Knight takes pawn takes rook takes and
then I think I just won upon although
actually this Queen would be able to
play to d5 hit my rook and then a2 so I
don't know if I like that so what to do
here let's try actually maybe maybe e6
hitting the Queen I'm not sure what do I
do here Knight takes pawn takes Knight
rook takes Queen d5 what do I have from
there I don't like that my rook would
then be getting hit
actually I'm gonna go forward with that
and I'm gonna follow up with Queen 2e -
so my queen my rooks going to be getting
hit very soon after what black plays
Queen to d5 I'm gonna play Queen e to
let him grab the a to pawn if he really
wants to and my follow up idea is gonna
be Yi six so e six I'm gonna be looking
to maybe just get some sort of a
weakness on the black King side
possibilities for maybe playing Knight
g5 at some point 95 at this point I'm
not so sure that that would work it's
protecting my rope but then it could be
kicked away with h6
and I also have to kind of keep in mind
the time issue here so my rook is
protected here so I do have to watch out
for possible Knight captures on d4
hitting this rook but thankfully it is
protected by my Bishop I'm just looking
to play e6 at this point so if Queen
takes a two I'm going to do east six but
then again east six allows this bishop
to come to life but really what else is
there I think I kind of have to maybe do
that move so I think we'll be seeing f5
hopefully I could maybe make use of this
this pawn which is just a couple squares
away from becoming very dangerous and
actually here it is as soon as I move my
rook here I'm extractant obstructing my
bishops view so I was just saying that
two seconds ago and now this tactic is
really this is really just gonna hurt me
real bad actually I think that's game
over so this is this has really really
backfired on me
rook to rook to e3 this whole idea of
pushing with e6 not so hot I don't think
there's anything anything good at this
point I'm just gonna I'm gonna lose big
time what do I do
I guess I guess I have to do that move
Queen to f1 and then if if Knight takes
I have to capture with my rook so that
my rook would be defended here actually
I was just getting ready to resign at
that point so let's see what black could
do I maybe there is a way to still make
use of this pond
or actually maybe just go into Blitz
mode I guess this is this really turned
out to be very ugly f5 advanced was very
nice hits the rook and I really didn't
have too many choices actually with my
rook at that point I think maybe I was
forced to go to e3 but I guess just
looking forward 40 seconds to 35 so
hopefully this guy's a little bit slow
otherwise I'd be beat
so rook takes Bishop takes pre move mode
and what do i do what do I do
okay Blitz mode I guess I should have I
should have maybe got my rook doing
something first
let's get that pawn out of the bishops
view and this guy's moving pretty quick
well at least I have a flight square I
guess mmm
Queen H queen a5 Queen a6 what do I do
okay try and get my Queen here I guess
it's really tough to even commentate at
this point I just hung my bishop maybe I
could get my pawn here or not
Brooksie 6o is this is this mate or
something no it's not me
I could I could win the Queen but I'm
gonna probably end up losing on time or
not actually mates coming up Wow very
lucky who very close I don't even know
if I want to go back and look at that
game but hopefully you're able to get
something out of it take care bye